de ninguna manera lo cierto es que hace
bastante acabo de pasar por la plaza de
tánger y para intentar hacer nuestra
conexión desde allí es imposible la
policía me lo ha impedido y eso muestra
muy claramente que el régimen no tiene
ninguna intención no solo no de
conmemorar sino de enterrar lo más
posible esta celebración de hecho hoy
que es el día de la policía el
presidencial del fatah él sí sí está
previsto que asista a la conmemoración
de esa de esa fiesta y precisamente fue
este día cuando se marcaron las
protestas de enero de 2011 para luchar o
para protestar contra la policía para
poder pedir paz para pedir libertad
democracia justicia social para pedir
dignidad algo que con el paso de los
años el régimen no ha ahorrado en
esfuerzos para acabar con ello así que
los que participaron en aquellas
protestas los que han seguido luchando
los años posteriores incluso las
familias de los que han terminado sus
días en la cárcel o en el exilio están
celebrando el día en la intimidad lo
están recordando algunos intentarán
también
por la plaza aunque será muy difícil
porque las fuerzas de seguridad tienen
toda la zona controlada desde hace
varios días
diez años después quedan vivos algunos
de los ideales por los que se luchaba
podría el país vivir una nueva
revolución
por supuesto y lo más importante y lo
que reconoce en la mayor parte de los
activistas y miembros de la sociedad
civil es que se rompió la barrera del
miedo se perdió el miedo a hablar sobre
todo y se ganó en confianza a los
egipcios recuperaron su país sintieron
egipto les pertenecía y que podían
reclamarlo así me lo explicaba gamal ahí
hace solamente unos días el abogado que
fundó la red árabe para la información
de derechos humanos pero además muchos
otros activistas como los que estáis
mostrando en estas imágenes acabo de ver
a zonas igualada del fatah siguen
luchando siguen protestando para que las
demandas del 25 de enero se vuelvan a
app
se vuelvan a conseguir se vuelvan a
mantener y si al menos se consiga pedir
a pesar de la represión y a pesar de de
la connivencia o de la complicidad de
occidente que sí se respeten los
derechos humanos es muy importante
recordar que una de las principales
demandas de aquellos días fue la
dignidad y la justicia social algo que
no se ha conseguido a pesar de que se
produzcan leves mejoras en la economía
la situación de los egipcios es
dramática a nivel de calle la gente
tiene muchas dificultades para
sobrevivir económicamente y son muchos
los egipcios que todavía siguen
denunciando y siguen pidiendo al régimen
que se produzcan esos avances que
soñaron contener el 25 de enero que se
han quedado de alguna manera en suspenso
pero que siguen ilusionando a muchos